michel fayyad les analystes politiques
et financiers bonjour à vous merci
d'être avec nous en direct ce soir sur
arte france
ces explosions ça représente quoi pour
le liban aujourd'hui dont l'économie
s'effondre bonsoir oui le port en fait
se représente énormément dans l'économie
du pays parce que comme vous a dit votre
reportage c'est les importations les
exportations du pays et donc même sa
production
les ports au liban c'est c'est toute son
histoire parce que le liban c'était
l'histoire de la phénicie c'était ses
ports c'était son commerce vers le monde
entier que ce soit en interne
d'exportation d'importation
c'est toute son histoire toute sa vie
économique qui est touché comment le
pays va pouvoir se relever on sait que
avance l'avant cet événement tragique
il y avait des négociations en cours
avec le fmi beaucoup de mécontentement
ou si on sert du gouvernement du
mécontentement aussi dans la rue comment
le pays peut se relever aujourd'hui déjà
déjà en terme de reconstruction du port
on parle de 3 à 5 milliards de dollars à
cela il faut ajouter ce que le
gouvernement était en train de négocier
avec le fmi
donc on parle de 5 à 10 milliards et ce
qui était prévu par la conférence être à
paris il ya quelques années qui était de
11 milliards de dollars qui était donc
qu'ils sont à être ajoutés aux as qui
est promis par le fmi
donc c'est une enveloppe importante le
problème aujourd'hui au liban c'est
qu'il ya une en fait un conflit larvé
entre autres les partisans du du plan du
gouvernement qui est qui et un plan
acceptable par le fmi et dont les
chiffres ont été validés par le fmi et
de l'autre côté les banques et les
politiciens qui ont des conflits
d'intérêts avec celle ci et qui ont
présenté un plan d' alternative qui
consiste à vendre en fait les réserves
d'or de la banque centrale
la façade maritime du pays où les biens
immobiliers de l'état
et ça c'est inacceptable par le fmi et
par les libanais il ya aussi l'appui de
de certaines puissances je pense
notamment à la france à mâcon est
attendu demain
au liban on sait que la france demandent
justement avait demandé aux autorités
libanaises de mener des réformes pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir justement obtenir
l'appui de paris oui tout à fait en fait
les réformes sont nécessaires et
indispensables et sont même les la
condition de l'aide du fmi et donc de la
france est en fait ces réformes n'ont
jamais eu lieu depuis 1990 les
gouvernements libanais successifs ont
menti à la communauté internationale ont
menti au peuple libanais et donc ces
réformes doivent définitivement avoir
lieu ce sont des réformes du secteur de
l'électricité des réformes au niveau de
la poule du modèle économique qui doit
passer d'une économie rentière et une
économie productive de dans le secteur
agricole secteurs industriels qui sont
justement touché par ce qui est arrivé
avec le port hier mais également une
restructuration du système bancaire qui
ne peut plus fonctionner comme il
fonctionner jusqu'à maintenant c'est à
dire en ponctionnant les les dépôts des
des gens et surtout des immigrés les
décideurs des libanais de la diaspora
est en fait il faut donc faire en sorte
que les banques libanaises retrouve le
véritable rôle qu'elles doivent avoir
c'est à dire un rôle de support aux
secteurs productifs et innovateur de
l'économie libanaise
demain madame a conquis devrait
présenter un programme selon les dires
de jean yves le drian aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui peut proposer une manière
d'un cran selon moi je pense qu emmanuel
macron doit vraiment mettre la pression
sur les plats classe politique pour
qu'elle accepte des réformes parce que
jusque là le gouvernement n'a pas réussi
à conclure ses négociations avec le fmi
et à faire valider son plan qui a été
acceptée par le fmi en raison des
blocages qui se situe au niveau du
parlement par une partie des députés qui
sont acquis au secteur bancaire qui est
contre le plan du gouvernement
d'ailleurs sur le terrain au liban on
parle d'un partie des banques qui
rassemble en fait les les actionnaires
des banques et des politiciens ayant des
conflits d'intérêts c'est à dire qu'ils
sont
les actionnaires de bank qui sont
membres des conseils d'administration de
banque consultant de banques avocats de
banque et donc c'est un véritable
conflit d'intérêt qui porte préjudice
aujourd'hui au liban parce que vous
imaginez que un député qui il a en fait
un problème est ce qu'il représente le
peuple qui l'a élu ou les citoyens qui
l'ont élu ou alors les banques qui
l'emploie ou ou dont il est actionnaire
donc il ya un véritable problème de
conflit d'intérêt il faut absolument que
qu emmanuel macron et la communauté
internationale mette vraiment la
pression maximale sur la classe
politique pour qu'elle accepte un plan
de réforme acceptée par le fmi une
question encore ça concerne l'origine
justement de cette double explosion hier
soir 2001 stock de 2007 150 tonnes de
nitrate d'ammonium que c'est ton est ce
que vous avez vous des informations sur
les propriétaires de cet entrepôt situé
dans le port est est ce que les
autorités pouvaient ignorer la présence
de ce stock
on rappelle que le premier ministre
libanais hassan diab a affirmé que les
responsables seraient punition oui il ya
une enquête en cours aujourd'hui
par contre il est évident qu'il ya eu un
problème de gestion de la part des
différents gouvernements parce que c'est
un stock qui existe depuis plusieurs
années et donc ne s'est pas vraiment ce
gouvernement actuel qui est responsable
mais plutôt les gouvernements qui est
qui était précédemment parce que je
rappelle ce gouvernement est en place
depuis sept mois
c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas accompli grand
chose jusque là mais le fait est que les
principaux responsables sont les
gouvernements précédents qui en fait
comme je disais tout à l'heure depuis
1990 n'ont rien fait que faire de la
corruption ne pas faire de réformes et
de en fait mentir à la communauté
internationale est mal géré les
infrastructures du pays mal géré le
budget que les citoyens de leur confier
en fait pour gérer le pays
et là c'est vraiment d'aidé en fait un
problème de gestion des du port et on
parle de la responsabilité des
différents direct des différents
directeurs de ports met également fin
des politiciens qui était censée les les
les surveiller ou les remplacer s'il le
faut merci à vous michel fayard d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions
rappelle l'analyste politique et
financier